laissez-moi vous raconter une histoire
toujours censée passer oh je suis tellement content
d'être ici j'adore Paris Non
qu'est-ce qu'il a dit il va détruire
le monde c'est une expérience très intense
aussi bien hâte de la même avec un
public français a besoin d'un  une grande inondation
arrive, nous construisons une arche pour contenir l'
innocent
Jennifer était ma femme et mon bel esprit
il y a longtemps et depuis notre deuxième
mariage et je suis allé plutôt bien
Russell est un acteur phénoménal, c'était
passionnant pour moi de pouvoir retravailler avec
lui vous  sais qu'il donne tellement en
tant qu'acteur à l'autre acteur avec lequel il
travaille, il est tellement engagé avec le
matériel et avec tout le monde autour de lui, cela
commence les types de sujets que
cela soulève, vous savez des choses comme notre
intendance de la planète notre
relation avec  animaux vous savez ce qu'est la
spiritualité pour
vous savez l'individu d'une personne donnée
ce que c'est pour vous et je pense que toute œuvre
d'art qui fait cela est une
chose merveilleuse vous êtes seul et me définissez je
ne suis pas seul quand th  Ils viendront ils seront
désespérés il y en aura beaucoup
je pense que Darrin va faire un
travail magnifique tu sais je pense que la façon
dont il a réinventé le monde
c'est vraiment un visionnaire il est très audacieux
et je pense que c'est vraiment rafraîchissant de
voir un film de ce genre  de budget entre les
mains de quelqu'un avec tant d'audace
et de créativité c'est un film qui
brise les attentes à tant de choses
il y a vous savez c'est énorme son épopée
c'est spectaculaire c'est moderne c'est ancien
c'est intemporel c'est émouvant c'est trop
difficile à résumer il y a  un pilote dans ce
film qui amène les gens à un niveau très profond
quand ils ont expérimenté que l'
intensité est telle qu'ils veulent
s'asseoir et discuter, ils veulent en
parler vous savez
Russell Crowe le
plus un merci beaucoup pour
venant ce soir Missy a rendu hommage
pour avoir visité votre nourriture
Je pense que ce serait très
différent de ce à quoi vous vous attendiez la
belle pas dans le choix du théâtre
était entre vos mains maintenant
bonjour tout le monde s'il vous plaît  venez voir notre film
bon vous bouge